încâlcirea cuantică permite particulelor să fie legate indiferent de spațiul dintre ele — acest lucru este atât de contraintuitiv
încât chiar și Einstein nu credea că este adevărat. În episodul de astăzi din Qiskit în clasă, vom vorbi despre cum teorema lui Bell a dovedit că Einstein
a greșit
bun venit la Qiskit în clasă. În această serie, vom folosi Qiskit pentru a explora câteva concepte fundamentale acoperite frecvent
în cursuri legate de Quantum Computing. Fiecare videoclip va fi însoțit și de un modul interactiv
legat în descrierea de mai jos, deci asigură-te că îl verifici. În videoclipul despre monede cuantice am discutat cum măsurarea unei
superpoziții cuantice este un proces intrinsec probabilistic, asemănător cu aruncarea unei monede în unele privințe, dar cum știm
asta? Ar putea fi că o particulă cuantică ascunde în secret un rezultat predeterminat al unei măsurători, dar noi cumva nu reușim să
captăm această informație în teoria noastră? În primele zile ale mecanicii cuantice, această întrebare a fost subiectul
unor dezbateri aprinse, cu două tabere principale. Într-o tabără era Einstein, care credea că mecanica cuantică era incompletă,
adică îi lipseau niște variabile necesare pentru a descrie complet un sistem. Einstein credea că
aceste așa-numite variabile ascunse, dacă ar fi găsite, ar rezolva unele aspecte aparent paradoxale și probabilistice
ale mecanicii cuantice. În cealaltă tabără era Max Born. Born a argumentat
că descrierea probabilistică oferită de mecanica cuantică este tot ceea ce specifică natura. Cu alte cuvinte,
nu e doar că nu cunoaștem starea unei particule înainte de a o măsura — e că particula nu are o stare definită
înainte de a fi măsurată. Timp de decenii, mulți au crezut că acest dezacord era o întrebare filozofică ce s-ar putea să nu fie
niciodată rezolvată. La urma urmei, pentru a afla orice despre un sistem trebuie să îl măsurăm. Cum putem afla
ceva despre natura unei stări înainte de măsurarea ei? Apoi, în 1964, fizicianul
John Bell a găsit o cale. În lucrarea sa, Bell a examinat corelațiile statistice dintre măsurătorile unei perechi de
particule încâlcite. Dacă înainte de măsurătoare stările particulelor ar fi fost determinate de niște variabile ascunse necunoscute,
Bell a constatat că corelațiile lor au o limită superioară. Pe de altă parte, când a calculat
corelațiile prezise de mecanica cuantică, a constatat că acestea depășesc această limită. Astfel a găsit o modalitate de a
diferenția o dată pentru totdeauna între viziunea lui Einstein și cea a lui Born. Tot ce mai rămânea era să testeze experimental
aceste corelații cu particule reale, pentru a vedea dacă respectă statistica variabilelor ascunse sau dacă
violează acea regulă. Aceste teste au fost efectuate cu precizie și sofisticare crescânde
de-a lungul anilor și sunt printre cele mai semnificative experimente ale fizicii moderne. Au fost atât de revoluționare încât
au adus premiul Nobel pentru trei fizicieni în 2022. Dar în zilele noastre oricine poate efectua un
test Bell. Tot ce avem nevoie este puțină cunoaștere de Qiskit și acces la un computer cuantic IBM. În acest videoclip voi
explica logica inegalității lui Bell, iar apoi vă voi arăta cum putem testa predicțiile lui Bell pe un calculator
cuantic IBM. Inegalitatea lui Bell implică câteva măsurători diferite și straturi de logică și poate fi
puțin dificil de urmărit, dar vom parcurge totul pas cu pas și la final va merita. Suntem pe cale să demonstrăm
că încâlcirea este reală și că Einstein greșește — nu prea mulți oameni pot spune că au făcut asta. Deci, iată
ce a propus Bell: să presupunem că ai o modalitate de a produce multe copii ale unei perechi de particule încâlcite. Din punct de vedere fizic,
aceste perechi ar putea fi produse printr-un proces de dezintegrare, unde o particulă se dezintegrează în două. Dacă ai urmărit videoclipul despre
experimentul Stern-Gerlach știi că particulele pot avea un moment cinetic intrinsec numit
spin. Să spunem că o particulă cu spin zero se dezintegrează în două particule cu spin 1/2
atunci fiecare dintre particulele cu spin 1/2 poate fi măsurată ca având fie spin plus 1/2, fie minus
1/2, numite și spin up sau spin down. Dar deoarece s-au dezintegrat dintr-o particulă cu spin zero, cele două trebuie să se combine pentru a
avea un spin total de zero. Deci, dacă una este măsurată ca up, cealaltă trebuie să fie
down și viceversa. Aceste particule formează o pereche încâlcită care arată astfel
deci dacă una este măsurată ca up, cealaltă este down și viceversa. Să spunem că particula unu zboară spre stânga, adică în direcția minus X, unde un cercetător pe care îl vom numi Lucas îi măsoară
spinul. Apoi particula doi zboară similar spre dreapta
unde un alt cercetător, Rihanna, poate măsura acel spin. Lucas și Rihanna pot în mod independent
roti dispozitivele de măsurare pentru a alege să măsoare spinul particulelor respective de-a lungul oricărei direcții
perpendiculare pe direcția de mișcare a particulei. Dacă trimitem multe copii ale stării încâlcite la Lucas
și Rihanna, ei pot colecta statistici de măsurare. Dacă măsoară întotdeauna de-a lungul aceluiași ax, aceste statistici nu vor fi
foarte interesante: de fiecare dată când unul măsoară spin up, celălalt măsoară spin down, și de fiecare dată când unul măsoară spin
forward, celălalt măsoară spin backward, și așa mai departe. Dar dacă cei doi cercetători măsoară de-a lungul unor axe diferite, putem găsi
ceva mai interesant. Să îi dăm lui Lucas și Rihannei trei axe de-a lungul cărora să
măsoare. Vom numi aceste axe a, b și c, și sunt fiecare separate prin
120°. Întrebarea pe care o vom pune cu acest experiment este: dacă Lucas și Rihanna sunt liberi să măsoare de-a lungul oricăreia dintre cele trei
axe, cât de des vor obține cei doi același semn? Clar, dacă Lucas și Rihanna se întâmplă să măsoare de-a lungul aceluiași ax,
să spunem axa a, nu pot obține niciodată același semn, deoarece particulele trebuie să se combine pentru a avea spin zero. Dar când aleg
axe diferite, cum vor fi corelate măsurătorile lor, dacă vor fi? Conform lui Einstein, această descriere
cuantică mecanică a stării particulei este incompletă. El credea că trebuie să existe variabile ascunse care
predetermină rezultatul tuturor măsurătorilor posibile de spin. Fără aceasta, particulele încâlcite ar trebui să
comunice cumva instantaneu rezultatul măsurătorii lor una alteia. Dacă una este măsurată ca
up aici, cealaltă trebuie să știe instantaneu că trebuie să fie down acolo.
Aceste variabile ascunse ar putea fi orice set complicat de instrucțiuni pentru rezultatul experimentelor, dar ideea este
că starea de spin a fiecărei particule separat este determinată, deci nu este necesară nicio comunicare.
că starea de spin a fiecărei particule separat este determinată, astfel încât nicio comunicare nu este necesară.
Din punct de vedere experimental, asta ar însemna că măsurătorile făcute de Lucas nu ar avea niciun efect asupra particulei lui Rihanna și viceversa.
Aceasta ar putea impune niște limite asupra cât de corelate pot fi cele două măsurători. Conform lui Born, totuși, această stare
psi este tot ceea ce se poate spune despre perechea de particule înainte de măsurare. Deci măsurarea unei particule
afectează rezultatul măsurătorii celeilalte. Aceasta poate avea implicații diferite pentru corelațiile dintre măsurători. Să vedem cum fiecare
teorie afectează aceste corelații. În tratamentul cu variabile ascunse există un set secret de instrucțiuni înainte de
măsurare care determină deja ce va măsura Lucas de-a lungul fiecăruia dintre cele trei axe. De exemplu, aceste
instrucțiuni ar putea fi: pozitiv dacă Lucas măsoară de-a lungul axei a,
pozitiv dacă măsoară de-a lungul lui b și negativ dacă măsoară de-a lungul lui c. Putem
scrie asta ca plus a, plus b și minus c. Atunci particula lui Rihanna
ar trebui să aibă variabilele minus a, minus b și plus c, pentru a se asigura că spinul total
de-a lungul oricărei direcții unice este zero.
Există opt seturi de instrucțiuni posibile care satisfac această constrângere de spin zero, deci de fiecare dată când o nouă pereche de
particule este trimisă lui Lucas și Rihannei, ar putea conține oricare dintre aceste opt seturi de instrucțiuni. Acum vrem să
calculăm, presupunând că particulele conțin unul dintre seturile secrete de instrucțiuni date în tabel și
presupunând că Lucas și Rihanna aleg fiecare în mod independent de-a lungul căreia dintre cele trei axe să măsoare, care este
probabilitatea ca amândoi să măsoare același semn? Dacă instrucțiunile sunt cele date în rândurile 1 sau
8, atunci clar această probabilitate este zero, deoarece cele două particule vor avea semne opuse indiferent de axele lor de
măsurare. Dar ce se întâmplă cu instrucțiunile din rândul doi? Ar măsura același semn dacă
Rihanna măsoară de-a lungul lui c și Lucas de-a lungul lui a sau b, sau dacă Lucas
măsoară de-a lungul lui c și Rihanna de-a lungul lui a sau b. Deci sunt patru din nouă din
combinațiile posibile de măsurare care le vor da lui Lucas și Rihannei același semn. Dacă facem asta pentru
fiecare set de instrucțiuni, vei vedea că rândurile 3 până la 7 dau de asemenea o probabilitate de 4/9. Asta înseamnă că dacă
Einstein are dreptate și variabile ascunse ca acestea predetermină rezultatul măsurătorilor, nu există nicio modalitate ca Lucas
și Rihanna să măsoare vreodată același semn cu o probabilitate mai mare de 4/9. Aceasta este inegalitatea Bell: P mai mic sau
egal cu 4/9. Și, așa cum vom arăta, particulele încâlcite violează aceasta. Deci, pentru a
vedea ce prezice mecanica cuantică, să spunem că Lucas măsoară de-a lungul lui a. Pot să se întâmple două lucruri: fie măsoară spin up, deci
Rihanna ar măsura spin down de-a lungul lui a, fie măsoară spin down și Rihanna ar măsura spin up de-a lungul lui a. Dar noi
vrem probabilitatea ca Rihanna să măsoare același semn ca Lucas de-a lungul oricărei axe alese de ea, nu doar a. Dacă
ea măsoară de-a lungul lui b sau c, devine puțin complicat. Se dovedește că
dacă știi ce va măsura Rihanna cu 100% certitudine de-a lungul unei direcții, poți calcula probabilitățile
că va măsura up sau down de-a lungul oricărei alte axe cu puțină geometrie.
Dacă starea ta măsoară întotdeauna spin up de-a lungul unui ax, atunci probabilitatea de a măsura spin up de-a lungul unui ax diferit
va fi egală cu pătratul cosinusului a 1/2 din unghiul dintre cele două axe. E puțin complicat, dar
vă voi arăta ce înțeleg. Dacă Lucas măsoară spin up de-a lungul lui a, știm cu 100% certitudine că Rihanna ar măsura
spin down dacă ar măsura a. Deci putem reprezenta asta cu un vector
ca acesta. În acest caz, unghiurile dintre acest vector și celelalte două axe de măsurare b și c sunt ambele de
60°. Deci 1/2 din asta este 30°, iar cosinusul lui
30° este arătat aici. Cosinusul la pătrat al lui
30° egal 3/4. Acum, ce se întâmplă dacă Lucas măsoară spin down
de-a lungul lui a? Știm că Rihanna ar măsura spin up de-a lungul lui a, deci putem desena un alt vector aici. Acum
acest vector care reprezintă această cunoaștere face 120° față de fiecare dintre celelalte două axe b
și c. Deci putem aplica același truc de geometrie, dar de această dată vom obține cosinusul lui
60°. Deci cosinusul la pătrat al lui
60° egal 1/4. Deoarece Lucas are șanse egale să
măsoare spin up și spin down de-a lungul lui a, trebuie să facem media acestor două probabilități ale lui Rihanna. Obținem în final o
probabilitate că Rihanna va măsura același semn ca Lucas de 1/2. Deci P
egal 1/2. 1/2 este mai mare decât 4/9, deci inegalitatea lui Bell este violată.
Asta înseamnă că atâta timp cât regulile mecanicii cuantice sunt valide, variabilele ascunse sunt imposibile. Acum putem folosi Qiskit și un
calculator cuantic IBM pentru a testa inegalitatea Bell cu măsurători cuantice reale. Putem mapa stările spin up și
spin down ale particulelor lui Lucas și Rihanna la stările zero și unu ale qubit-urilor din calculatorul cuantic. Vom
lua două qubit-uri, unul pentru a reprezenta particula lui Lucas și unul pentru cea a lui Rihanna, și le vom încâlci cu acest circuit cuantic.
Deci cele două qubit-uri sunt reprezentate de cele două fire q0 și q1, iar această combinație
de gate-uri X, Hadamard și CNOT va produce aceeași stare încâlcită pe care o aveam între particulele lui Lucas și Rihanna. Acum
trebuie să măsurăm fiecare qubit. Vom seta măsurarea lui Lucas să fie de-a lungul lui a, adică vom spune că este axa Z. Apoi măsurarea lui Rihanna
poate fi de-a lungul lui a, b sau c. Deci vom avea nevoie de trei circuit-uri separate pentru fiecare dintre aceste trei cazuri. Dar în acest
videoclip vom face doar unul. Poți merge la modulul din descriere pentru versiunea completă. Dacă Rihanna măsoară de-a lungul lui
b, atunci circuit-ul nostru arată astfel, unde Ry este o rotație de 120° pentru a schimba
axa de măsurare a lui Rihanna. Putem folosi Qiskit Primitive sampler pentru a rula acest experiment de multe ori și a colecta
statistici din măsurătorile rezultate. Cele două coloane 00 și 11 reprezintă momentele în care Lucas și
Rihanna au măsurat același semn, ceea ce ne interesează. Deci probabilitatea de a măsura ambele particule cu același
semn este aproape 1/2. Aceasta violează inegalitatea lui Bell. Asta înseamnă
WEBVTT
că cele două particule sunt încâlcite — fiecare pare să știe instantaneu rezultatele
măsurătorii celeilalte. Există în continuare unele dezacorduri despre cum să interpretăm exact aceasta
încâlcire și ce se întâmplă când măsori o stare încâlcită, dar aceste întrebări sunt mai mult filozofice.
Teoria este destul de incontestabilă în acest moment: încâlcirea este cu siguranță reală și știm asta mulțumită lui Bell, inegalității
sale și multora fizicieni care au efectuat experimente pentru a o testa. Dacă vrei să fii numărat printre acei
fizicieni și să efectuezi propriul tău test Bell cu un calculator cuantic, asigură-te că mergi la modulul inegalității Bell
din descriere. Mulțumesc că ai urmărit și ne vedem data viitoare.